was hierzu bot ihn so ungemein lässig um
den hals trägt ist keine medaille das
ist eine eintrittskarte sein ticket zur
freiheit wenn man so alles gut wird
treten sie ein
auch wenn er heute alleine in seiner
moskauer stammkneipe sitzt nämlich
dürfen nur noch geimpfte genesene und
getestete und wird das nachweisen will
braucht seit kurzem einen qr-code der
ist mangelware weil die behörden mit dem
ausstellen nicht hinterherkommen tom hat
seinen in viel gold und glitzer
eingefasst ich wollte eigentlich nur
einen spaß machen aber journalisten sind
darauf aufmerksam geworden
heute haben wir auch social media
geschrieben wir wollen auch andere haben
mich bestimmt
[Musik]
die band spielt nicht mehr in diesen
tagen das bisschen bier und wein das
noch getrunken wird läuft zumeist auf
sommer terrassen oder auf der straße die
kehlen herunter
noch vor wenigen wochen sah das ganz
anders aus kann ich biete meinen kaffee
haben ein anderes moskauer lokal die
gleichen sorgen alexander matu noch
braucht eigentlich kein koffein um wach
zu werden die ganze lage regling
gastronom sowieso ziemlich auf er fragt
sich wie soll das alles nur weitergehen
wir haben gerade so gut wie keine
einnahmen
wenn man uns jetzt auch noch die
terrassen wegnimmt wenn man auch dort
nur noch mit qr code essen und trinken
kann dann wird es sehr schwer für die
natur stellt sich wie viele russen vor
allem eine frage warum zieht die
regierung ausgerechnet zu spät
die zügel an wir hatten ein ganzes jahr
zeit den leuten zu erklären dass es zwei
möglichkeiten gibt entweder sie lassen
sich impfen oder es gibt eine dritte
welle jetzt plakate für die impfungen
aufzuhängen
man hätte das alles fließender und ohne
repressionen machen können die plakate
von denen alexander erzählt sehen so aus
wie viele müssen noch sterben bevor du
dich impfen lässt moskaus bürgermeister
sobjanin die russische regierung die
behörden sie machen ernst im kampf gegen
korona aber sie machen jetzt erst ernst
von anfang an hatte die russische
regierung keine konsequente corona
politik keine klare aussage die den
bürgern vermittelt hätte das virus ist
gefährlich und nur die impfungen kann
das problem eindämmen
es sind zu viele zu viele tote diese
särge im sankt petersburger krematorium
sind nicht leer
rund 700 menschen sterben in russland
jeden tag mit dem corona virus es ist
nicht zu übersehen zu lange wurde zu
wenig getan noch vor kurzem em spiele in
sankt petersburg trotz delta variante
zehntausende im stadion leidenschaft und
leichtigkeit jetzt katerstimmung nach
dem rausch brauchen sie meine
sozialversicherungsnummer die habe ich
hier schauen sie einfach zu wie ich das
ausfüllen und machen sie es mir nach
taxifahrer rosberg karibik aufspürt am
eigenen leib wie der kreml seine
strategie ändert in dem land in dem koma
fast ein jahr lang kein thema war gibt
es jetzt eine quasi impfpflicht wer
nicht mitmacht wird freigestellt vom job
ohne gehalt rosberg ist im größten im
zentrum moskaus es fällt ihm nicht
leicht
man zwingt uns unbedingt bis zum 15
das ist die frist war es eine leichte
entscheidung nein ich habe zuerst
informationen gesammelt
beamte ärzte lehrer gastronomen
zehntausende sind es die den pieks jetzt
brauchen wenn sie weiter arbeiten
möchten
rosberg und die anderen stehen teilweise
stundenlang schlange haben sie jetzt
schmerzen nein ich fühle gar nichts aber
man sehen was noch kommt mit sputnik hat
der kreml politik gemacht weltpolitik
den eigenen impfstoff der international
gelobt wurde verkauft in die halbe welt
ein milliardengeschäft
in den ersten paar linien monat in riesa
im staatlichen fernsehen und aus anderen
offiziellen quellen immer das virus sei
nicht gefährlich der westen sei
hysterisch wegen corona dass er alles
nicht so schlimm und werde bald vorbei
sein
parallel dazu aber wurde eiligst am
impfstoff geforscht allen war klar wer
zuerst kommt macht das große geld
konkurrenz schadet da nur und deshalb
gab es seitenhiebe auch von höchster
stelle
mittlerweile sind schon mehr als 20
millionen 23 millionen geimpft alles ist
in ordnung
und gott sei dank sind wir nicht mehr
zur tragischen situationen konfrontiert
die sie bei astrazeneca oder tiger
vorkommen
larissa droste hat den präsidenten
vermutlich gehört aber trotz des
staatlichen drucks trotz der toten und
erkrankten larissa will nicht sie ist
nicht allein
dieser impfstoff der innerhalb weniger
monate entwickelt worden ist wie können
wir wissen dass er keine nebenwirkungen
hat
darum haben die menschen angst und wegen
dieses drucks larissa und die anderen
impfgegner treffen sich jeden samstag am
puschkin platz in moskau rund die hälfte
aller russen lehnen eine impfung ab
und so ist das netz voll von kritik von
zweifel und manchmal auch von humor
glückwunsch jetzt müssen sie von corona
keine angst mehr haben vielen dank
wer nicht will der impft auch nicht sie
will ganz offenbar nicht und viele
andere sehen es ähnlich das hat viel mit
dem russischen impfstoff zu tun aber
genauso viel mit der frage ob man der
eigenen regierung trauen kann
[Musik]